you're gonna die so soon
no I will leave so you're coming forever
just combining some bullets I mean do
you think I'm gonna be into some [ __ ]
pretty soon like maybe I was she getting
some heavy artillery I hope I've been
shotgun and handgun for awhile I got
this
Magnum I got this I got these freeze
rounds what do those go in are you
serious yeah they go in a Magnum just
look really big
are they grenades yeah it's the same
exact shape as the grenade box I forget
it was to down from it right that makes
sense all right cool don't make us
there's the key of god thing I just like
did some hot combining mm-hmm all right
where are we going back downstairs
to unlock that door do I have everything
I need I don't know if you need that cog
but you can bring it gear
Kadir oh I'm hurt that's all right I
saved stop butchering that song and my
ears and chewing any like that's mmm
noise annoys me everything annoys you
Erick thohir GameSpot brought in some
holiday no he didn't his beautiful
girlfriend did oh where I forgot about
spiders should I just kill them no just
go
do their full would never backward
excelsior and always twirling twirling
towards freedom what that the Russian
ballets it is a Simpsons reference
to win really okay it's gonna go down
puzzles are very hard
cobwebs just go man oh there's a peasy
lemon school they just clutter the area
whoa
check those bods
what's that green arrow of smell look
what does that mean give me music's bad
it's only been three hours since the
mission started but the team is down to
me and Kimball the number of zombies is
far greater than they expected no hope
we injected the antibody for the virus
but I'm not sure it will work we reached
the clock tower we robbed some wounded
members of their weapons and used the
surviving citizens as decoys dark we
were taught to do this in order to
survive in the battlefield okay
she looks like my sister before she
starved
[Music]
I wonder if that was due at the
beginning
I know that's what you're everything you
know cuz is that the girl mm-hmm
my thing huh
there's your clock puzzle
yeah
I don't think I should take that yeah
don't take it yet see what the other two
are
you also don't have three spots I don't
think
oh yeah you know
crystal obsidian emerald amber
I'll just flies trapped in amber
all right
okay so you have to place those balls in
to put your hands together to pray
before the goddess give your soul to the
goddess put your hands together to pray
before her okay I'll go back to the
statues past guys put your hands
together to pray before her so it's the
two on the side and then the middle one
was the hands are together on the right
and left
amber obsidian and crystal yeah how do I
know which one is which go look at the
actual statues what they all think
I think you could pick them up anyway
wait I could maybe there's like
some hot info I can't pick this up I'm
out of room you could and then just do
two of the balls at a time just don't
pick it up yet
nemesis he's gonna bust through that
door if you're not fast enough okay so
I'm gonna take one they're all wait look
see what they're doing so this one the
one with the amber is doing look at this
was the middle one doing click on it
her hands are together
yeah but
oh okay wait a minute wait a minute okay
hear me out on this one crystal balls
see the future right I'm not kidding
no no are you why are you laughing one
of those was the past when was those the
future put the crystal ball in the
future one
amber usually trapped like old things
like fossils in amber that would be past
maybe obsidians present I'm probably
thinking too hard about but try it
you're probably thinking too hard about
it what you don't me take that yeah take
it no I'm just saying like I think it
makes it I'm not saying you're wrong I
just feel like you're thinking a lot but
that's fine look past future and present
right which one is the future the one of
your crystal ball yeah on the right says
future so obsidian is middle I guess so
but I said put your hands together to
pray
so don't do this one first I don't know
if that matters but get the other two
first the balls
all right I'll get the other balls
ladies give me your balls
alright ok so the first one try amber
so you'd have to get the hands together
oh that makes way more sense than what
you said no it's still but okay but
watch try just try crystal in the future
okay all right so do that before I don't
know yeah just try
and then obsidian I guess
huh damn thought I was on something okay
we want a flibbidee flew them flip the
two right ones because it seemed like
amber got you pretty close amber on the
left you just do process of elimination
from here on out I guess
it was a good it was a good idea then I
just liked your first sentence that's
all that's the only thing that made me
laugh what did I say crystal balls see
into the future they do that's like the
well that's what you missed magic
magicians fortune tellers would like you
to thank yes try this there's a lot of
options could take a really long time oh
damn it I keep doing the wrong thing
damn
maybe you reverse the left two now and
then if that doesn't work you just have
to swap these ones that's the last
combination
it's probably a more intelligent way to
do this but we're just playing logic
here we are though yeah this is all
assuming the order you do them and
doesn't matter just where they are
oh wait so we do this that will harm it
mm-hmm
so this isn't right it just says the
hands to have to be together doesn't
have to be midnight right
do you have it that wouldn't
alright now swap the outside - so lash
combination I can think of there are no
more combination
[Music]
the clock is down so maybe they do want
which one was on the right it's crystal
right
the embers in the middle course old I
forget no no yeah yeah go crystal there
did we just do
dang it
hmm
hmm indeed
try putting amber in the future
yeah we didn't do that before have we I
don't even know anymore
I think these yeah there's more than six
comedies in the future
you just do the same thing I wasn't
nowhere
oh my god I thought it froze I thought
it did too
all right I can switch the middle in the
first one now
of course it's gonna be the last one I
don't think we're doing it right
Oh what do you think we're doing wrong
is about the order
take it Mary all right so
No so crystal changes increments by 1
hour huh huh
obsidian does two increments amber does
3 sweet well that was dumb
there you go probably eat that one her
they can get those magnum rounds or
whatever they were - cheese why is the
menu taking so long
no cuz we suck at that puzzle oh you
combine them or just use that one
upstairs
Oh Chronos here yeah does magnum rounds
though oh right I think that's what they
were to do you remember which order they
were in in case I die no I don't see I
see I don't even think it matters the
order you have to like use them it's
like a math thing no I meant like which
which ones were where as I'm saying it
doesn't it doesn't really that's not
it's not as simple as that but yeah we
can check I don't know if it's gonna let
you interact with any more because no I
was not paying attention so I hope you
don't that
try clicking on one I can't click on all
right well let's not die and by let's I
mean you
well the [ __ ] gonna come after me I
can promise you that I got two full
heels but if he picks me up I'm gonna
die [ __ ] upstairs
spiders Oh God
what should I do just go or shock on
them people might be worth it at this
point yeah just run now don't worry
about it you got that thing that your
caution and poison but you got that blue
in the main room how do you know I'm a
caution and not in danger
because he hurt me if you were worried
that much you can use that that's blue
ready I don't want to all right no
Sprint's that one's flipped over you can
run
don't think you'll need to yeah you
might need to go back there that Bell
was there that door that Bell looked
important mm-hmm
go through here no I don't think so
that's back to the safe room oh right
I'm done nope you were right I'm right
you're dumb yeah
there's spiders up here
puppy chow is so good mm-hmm reveal dog
food is to get that away from me stay on
the ceiling
lest I pump your guts full of lead
snakes snakes snakes yeah I don't know
no snakes anything have happened
anything good happen all right insert
that Chronos gear
[Music]
wait a minute wait a minute okay here's
my suggestion they said that the
belltower would bring a helicopter
earn the yard out front and because you
have a decent mouse over it I would save
right here so I feel like something bigs
about to happen oh really
I would mean you have it you have like
six now right five or six you're fine I
have like nine either way I would save
you have to end the episode eight I I
trust you
nipples of intuition no this this is my
instinct I mean my toenails are telling
me
[Music]
because if you wanted the reason we're
stopping at forest I have a meeting but
after my meeting we could just leave
this on and come back do you think I
need the lockpick still I keep taking it
with me everywhere examine those just
make sure their magnum rounds
[Music]
Oh - so I think I should take something
important with me
bring the mine third maybe another like
a green herb I could do an easy combine
like I have enough I think said the
helicopters gonna go in the front yard
that he might even go down the tower
probably show something
[Music]
all right let's do it that reminds me of
the end of the first game remember when
it was like me man
man it was like scaring the crap out of
me I think you're going out front right
now I think you're right where I wonder
know the switch didn't work anymore so
you can
[Music]
nemesis is gonna rocket launch with that
thing out of the air
[Music]
guess again yeah okay sucks you have to
fight this dude now once and for all is
this the end
Carlos wait I didn't get a chance to do
anything about that I just start injured
virus no should I do that
so do I show virus leads me to believe
that it's something you can't really
just cure right now run can you not heal
with that baby you've heard him I'll
keep running he's gonna heal maybe just
might as well I mean you yeah I would
heal you see what it does that it helps
am I not feeling the virus remember it
helps no it did it oh did it bring me
right back didn't do [ __ ] alright okay
oh that's awesome buddy
what do you mean toss them at him I
don't know yeah shoot some minds like
you're gonna run into them like behind
you hey so how it works yeah oh nice
yeah shoot some mines I don't know
you're not shooting
that was lucky but also calculated
what then I hate you
my heel I'm gonna die heel now oh no
it's not gonna do anything never mind
sorry I don't what you're saying that
what do you mean it's not you that
didn't do anything last time you had the
virus great but is it not still like
when I'm poisoned I still have health
issues
no but that's it's not poison it's a
virus it's different he infected you
with whatever virus I don't think - you
can try it it's not gonna do anything
well what I'm saying is I'm clearly
injured rebar you already worried you
didn't help you at all last time when
you did it I'm having a hard time
turning around damn it see I I'm like
really yes you're still gonna be a
little bit injured but all right
what oh yeah oh I don't think you have
any lying around so we'll see I reloaded
[Music]
I'm gonna die
damnit I ran to the wrong arm get up get
up I died
goodbye we saved I don't think I
understand how the minds work I mean
you're just you were hitting him
directly I don't think you're they were
getting a chance so I'm supposed to put
them on the ground I'm you don't have to
you could bring the Magnum if you want
to finally I don't know if that's the
funnel fight though I don't I really
don't know hmm think I need more gun
power power
guys really hard to kill
damn I'm glad you convinced me to save
man I was smart all right cool so I do
need to go back to the save box and
reconstruct my plan well now you have to
fight him I'd say bringing you to the
Magnum of the grenade launcher you got
it
you have 12 grenade rounds and six
freeze rounds definitely don't need a
lockpick or
[Music]
I bring the grenade launcher and all the
rounds so that's all that and then I
could also bring the grenade lock or the
mine launcher do you think that's not
necessary
maybe pouring in case I wouldn't bring
the Magnum Irsay not tempted to use it
because I don't
oh yeah dream this don't worry about
bringing the mag okay and wait oh I
already had a mixed herb nice sweet
everything I feel pretty good I feel
pretty prepped
[Music]
just in case I would load the freeze
rounds in the grenade launcher because
if they actually do slow them down
though what happens with the other
rounds in there it'll just come out as a
regular Oh wit also are you sure yeah
let's do that so now you can combine
those two and bring something else if
you wanted to well you're smart maybe
you might as well just bring a green
herb or something if you you think I'm
gonna go through dreams no but I'm
saying if you have a space there's
nothing there's no harm to bring it in
just not using it maybe I'll need the
space for if you drop something when he
dies
[Music]
I got this so the question is do I hit
them with a freeze round first or do it
pop some mines on the ground
freeze rounds and then maybe when he's
frozen maybe throw some mines down if it
does freeze him probably doesn't you
skip this
you can if you hold a button or
something
[Music]
now whatever I like the despair of it
anyway
who's a dick
and then he immediately hurts me
well he's infecting the virus is like a
story point
[Music]
I really thought I juked that dodged
that and then get ready to shoot okay do
you think he'll come out give your shot
son of a
I hit him you have your shotgun oh oh
I'm the older yeah I thought I already
had it out probably want to heal no this
is not going well
Josh the rocket son of a-- oh crap crap
there's there's a [ __ ] unbelievably
rocket launcher
yeah it should turn around give a [ __ ]
he'll damn I made like we got to be
shoot you gotta like dodge and then get
ready to shoot I made a mistake it's
like running away he's gonna catch up to
you every time you gotta be ready to
shoot then just go mr. Sousa dude I just
made him I made like some freak bad
moves though and like I got hit by some
really unlucky rocket yeah I got like
stuck in a corner was not my best I
really thought I felt really prepared
that time but I wasn't prepared I died
everything okay so let's do this again
do you think I should even bring more
health now that I have that extra slot
do I even need the shotgun
[Music]
you have room we can't hurry to bring it
back up yeah
[Music]
oh this goes in here this goes this and
then I have room for one more
[Music]
oh right and then when I get rid of the
handgun I can bring
spring LIGO a green herb or something I
could combine those I guess let's bring
it for st. spring probably won't need
them all again I hope not I didn't even
get to use them last time
he just you got a time the rocket dodged
right like when he raised it you have
like two seconds before he fires and
then you gotta move or just keep moving
it was unfortunate that you ran into the
flower bed wall I felt I just felt like
I'm prepared or something
[Music]
down here
it's finally finally over
ah
he's so tough how come he needs a ride
do you have your shotgun equipped yes
thank you
run away first come this way though
so
to the freezer
all right so you will meet a run first
before I shoot him you didn't tell me he
was gonna have to
yo please I'm trying to help you you
didn't he last time and he died Oh son
of a for damn it
[Music]
Neal David he'll I'm trying
alright 180 and run
[Music]
goddamnit I ran into a strong hand pimp
it's nice shoot that [ __ ] nice shoot
that [ __ ] up
eight it's alright nice he missed me
yeah should I run then instead of here
no he'll now run and then shoe
good yeah like his [ __ ] body I think
you're probably gonna faint from the
buyers oh [ __ ]
oh shoot him Oh God reload
[Music]
just 180 and run
[ __ ]
Oh God nice shoot him nice okay
oh [ __ ] what yeah and then
died I can't get this for her to die
she yeah okay Wow
she she damn then we say them on I help
don't use all my help
thank you Brian yeah the dodging is
definitely helpful like the actual
dodging Carlos come get us
damn let's hope
alright here's my suggestion do not
overwrite the save we just had in case
we get a little farther in and you don't
have enough help from win a beat the
game just do you did I think you did
pretty well it's just like thank you I
think if you had the dodge down you
could have saved a couple of health I
think you're right
maybe she's not it's a my only
conception yeah am I gonna play as
Carlos it looks like our roles have been
reversed from when we originally met huh
don't worry Jill this Chapel is safe
I've been infected by the virus haven't
I hey take it easy
I'm okay don't feel any pain but that's
what bothers me if I can't feel anything
then what does that mean
don't give up Jill I'll take care of you
whatever you do don't let that virus
beat you it's not how viruses work maybe
a little bit
what items does he have on him already
gun gun ribbons all right so we're
probably saving right save all right I
get as much as is not overwrite your
most recent save you got it just in case
I will be that was the make a breakpoint
okay sweet well thank you guys for
watching me kill the nemesis we will see
you guys again on the next resident good
even your when I killed that guy
remember when I took you for hell's to
kill him there's no reason to do that
there's no reason to brag